foreign
next up we have Nancy calling from
Indianapolis Indiana hey Nancy welcome
to the show
hi thank you both and I just
accomplished
um
the will of God to get through today
I've had those burdened and I just
needed counseling and your wisdom so
thank you for taking my call thanks for
calling a shout out to your screener
you're welcome because he helped me try
to sum up my dilemma oh Austin is the
best in the game that's very kind
absolutely thank you okay basically my
my youngest niece is in college over in
Australia and she's about to enroll in
her third year this month or yes so
um her mom is really not involved in her
life
and so I felt burdened because at least
my niece and I have a relationship so I
feel burdened for her outcome for her
success so I've been helping her these
past couple years with her tuition and
living expenses although she has been
working the Lord's provided for her
but at this point with her third year
she doesn't see her schedule work really
working out for work so because her
mom's not really involved
what I guess part of my frustration is
Mom and I or her mom and I had received
an inheritance and she was given more
because he at the time she had three
dependents and this was in the last
six seven years
um
so I don't like it that I'm even feeling
mercenary I don't like that and I feel
like this is like a shining light on me
not trusting the Lord to provide for me
I'm looking at my inheritance so because
of this burden I feel to help my knee
succeed and I and I believe in her
because she had right now she has this
Vision this goal that's why he went into
University
and but because it's in a way straining
my wealth in a sense I want her mom to
step in what's going on with her mom
have conversation with her mom well
I guess bottom line
um she's in I to me it's a cult and I
felt for your previous caller I guess
two calls ago this is the Divide she was
saying it's just something weird to
happen her family well this is weird too
so the leaders has everybody turn their
backs and anybody who doesn't support
him
so I feel the Lord we're talking like a
religious cult like a Scientology level
situation
yeah well it's I think it's small base
but yeah and it's just it's been
devastating
um she my niece and I so I feel because
she was living overseas my niece went
over to Hillsong and it because of
Hillsong and then left and because her
goals change and it's just as well
because that church has had its own
share of problems so what is she doing
now
okay
um her goal is she went the children
went through foster care
he and her sisters so her heart is my
niece's heart has always been her
children
and she wants to be in like a social
care system that foster care
um which I commended for and she's still
in Australia
yes why isn't she back stateside family
there's no reason for her to come back
she doesn't I'm not enough to bring her
back you know it's like the whole family
has just divided themselves I imagine
College though is more expensive in
Australia for her than it would be here
well she's able I guess her expenses are
minimal because she's not able to do
anything you're floating her expenses
that's what I wondered okay I had that
thought so here's here's my honest take
on this Nancy
she needs to move back to the states she
needs to go to an in-state School
Community College because tomorrow her
goals might change again and Aunt Nancy
is floating all the expenses at the
detriment of her own financial situation
and she's just riding High riding free
and I understand you want to help her
but it feels like she's taking advantage
of you in a way
yeah okay do you feel that go ahead do
you feel that at all yes I don't think
it's malicious but I don't want you to
feel this burden emotionally that you
now have to be her mother and you need
to take care of her every expense she
can work I worked in college with a full
schedule graduated a half semester early
Christina worked it's possible and uh
I'm not saying she's out there partying
every day but as a student you have time
in between classes and in between
studying to work
and so I'm going to challenge that piece
of it and I'm also going to challenge
the fact that she needs to go Eat Pray
Love in Europe to get this degree to
take care of kids
do you agree am I more angry about this
than you are just I'm just hearing this
facts on paper for the first time I
kind of sunset I maybe I was just
hesitant to bring that up I felt either
you need to do this this and this or
you're coming home you're coming back I
just think you're a really sweet person
and I'm worried that you're becoming a
doormat for her to say well my life's
been hard mom's not in the picture Aunt
Nancy got this inheritance she's okay
and at the same time I don't want you to
have to delay your own retirement and
have no wealth and be in a really sucky
financial situation because you allowed
yourself to feel like a burden for this
girl okay okay just Free Yourself of
that
have you had any conversations with your
niece about this
oh well yes but not but not at the I
don't know not to the point where no you
need to consider coming home because I
can't be funding you I haven't had that
conversation how much are you giving her
per month
well if this I don't know if I can
average I did look at per year how much
have you given her the last few years
I'd say
maybe close to not I don't know if it's
even 20 000. I know the two-year tuition
in U.S money has been 32 to 34 000 per
year or over two years no for two years
I if you want to continue giving but
have boundaries around it you could say
Hey listen you're in your third year I'm
going to continue giving you let's say
500 a month for those two years the rest
is on you you need to work you need to
figure it out but this is as much as I
can do right now financially
okay and that's very generous on your
end and if you want to say hey I can no
longer do this starting tomorrow she's
gonna have to figure it out and she's
young and she's resilient uh and she
she's living on her own right in
Australia
yes yes and hey Nancy this may be a
non-point but
um does the mom still have inheritance
or did that go to the cult
yeah that thank you that's that's what
it's been I I know a big chunk of it is
gone to this cult do you know if there's
um with her getting more inheritance um
because of the three dependents do you
know if any of that money was in the
kids names or was it all in in your
sister's name I think it was in my
sister's name yeah and no other family
involved in this situation
no it's just seeing her two of her
daughters and even a granddaughter
okay so you feel like that money is gone
there there's probably no way to get
that to actually go towards pretty much
because my yes because my niece has
hinted his or felt as much that he
doesn't think her mom really is in the
position to give and maybe
that's why her she has her mom has an
offered to help her
gosh what a sad situation yeah well I
love your heart Nancy I really do I I
want the best for both of you and I
don't think that means you have to just
Fork over all of your money to fund her
life for an indescript amount of time I
don't think that's the best for either
of you
yeah Nancy you are so sweet
oh it's gonna take a hard conversation
with her and really get the details of
hey what is your plan here's how much
you need to also sit down and figure out
how much am I willing to give if any
more but not just an open bank account
for her to take from either
yeah and your heart is your heart is in
the right place and I think that there's
a lot of you know grief at the loss of
you know the relationship with your
sister there's grief that your niece was
in the foster care system there's a lot
of emotions tied into this but it's
important to kind of separate you know
what can you do from a mentor
perspective what can you do to love your
niece well versus what needs to happen
financially because you're not
responsible for what happened with their
mother and her finances that's that is
your sister's bad decisions and you
don't have to make up for it but I do
love your heart and your care for her
Nancy that that's you're a very sweet
woman but be willing to have that hard
conversation